while we're joined now by major-general
chip Chapman former head of
counter-terror Ministry of Defence
counter extremism practitioner of Middle
East academic Emma
Albert da we and also by Russia Dahlia
former radical and senior fellow at the
Institute for Strategic Dialogue thank
you all for joining us to talk about
this is a very interesting story first
of all rationally looking at that piece
there does that ring any bells with the
kind of work that you do does it how do
you relate to what you saw unfolding
there and that story I think what's
interesting is that you have two very
different a start point an end we know
how they perceive their religious
identity so on the one hand you have
this very strong political ideology you
know running through what he what he
believed was his religion one that
should be enforced over society one
which was separatist and one which
sought to be part of a greater global
Muslim community and at the end you have
someone who has taken a religion but
sees it as a practice for themselves
sees themselves as belonging to the
wider community rather than separate
from it and doesn't see their religion
as a political ideology but more a
spiritual path and I think somewhere
that journey is the interesting part to
try and map out exactly what it is that
created that shift and that change I
mean always a reconciliation with what
perhaps a discovery of what you really
wanted in the first place in that
possibly but I think the really
interesting thing is some of the
interviews he's mentioned that he never
felt an absence so he never really felt
the need for belonging he never really
felt that there was a void in his life I
mean however he does speak about when he
embraced Islam as an idea it appealed to
him and so I think in this instance I
think it's almost taking away all the
political ideology that surrounds the
religion and leaving just the spiritual
path that he was initially attracted to
whilst almost going back to where he was
before as someone who was settled within
the community and not separate from it
there are lots of individuals who like
you mentioned have that void and that's
what attracts them to the ideology
but in this instance I think it probably
wasn't the case general Chapman I mean
we think about military counterterrorism
we think of you much more they kind of
policing and military strategic side of
things but what was your take on what
you saw in that story there I think you
need to separate two things the first
powerful thing is that there was a
declaratory disengagement by him so he's
declared that he's against physical
force being used so that's a a good
thing
and of course you can declare yourself
against this in an overt sense a covert
sense and he's declared it on Sky News
so that's a really powerful thing and
can be very impacted that's different
than the cognitive processes that is as
he actually disengaged D radicalized in
terms of his attitudes and views now the
piece would suggest that that's partly
what he did but in a sense we'll have to
wait and see
so you're raised he might still be if
you like a kind of weapon that hasn't
been made completely safe I'm not
necessarily saying that but of course
the government had its counter counter
extremist strategy which came out on the
19th of October and of course that is to
do with British values as David Cameron
and the government said we're not quite
sure at the moment if he upholds British
values of democracy the rule of law and
inclusive society and religion being
something which is for all in all face
and all practices so we have a we have
an individual story there but we know of
course the big concern is the big
picture
governments police agencies other sort
of groups are all concerned about how we
tackle the big picture to make a kind of
a change what we saw there how does that
build into where we are in terms of the
UK and dealing with this issue as a
country well I mean I think this is an
example of a deal addict ization process
that is at least what we're thinking it
could be effective because this young
man standing and out and saying you know
I was wrong the issue and it comes back
to what you saying hit tip was that it
is an ongoing process and we're really
started to accept that but actually a
lot of our evaluation of demonization
processes assume that there's a success
by the end of it and actually defining
success is really impossible with these
things because it's just not measurable
and it's very unique to that individual
very personal
and one of the things that people are
trying to say as success is at the stage
when their individual is reintegrated
back into society and that is not what
people say is that that would be a sign
of a successfully radicalization process
the trouble is it's probably one of the
hardest parts of a dear analyzation
process in theory because it requires
not just the individual the individual
may really buy into the idea of getting
a job and reintegrating back into the
communities but it requires more than
that individual and that it requires
more people it requires the hospitality
of the white society to acknowledge yes
this person's D radicalized he's you
know he's on a journey and now he's back
with us and we'll open up to him having
a job and reintegrating and that's so
much harder because you're destroying a
culture which is kind of open and
welcome to the idea of people who may
have difficulties dealing with elements
of it being brought into the fold and
and money and time and effort being
spent on help in the matter and that's
that's a whole national challenge isn't
it no I think it's really really really
key actually the second part that
actually on an individual level there is
all these measures that people put in
place to what extending with ideology
does he no longer have intent to cause
harm there's this capacity in
connections that the individuals removed
and those measures are put in place an
analysis takes place but actually the
point that you mentioned that that to
what extent is there a reintegration of
that individual that is actually the
difficulty and I think with you the
interesting thing to look at is the
community aspect then actually there is
almost a recapturing back to the
community at least through what we saw
with the gym with Los Smyrna with the
kind of the Muslim communities there but
also with wider slightly not separate
from it and I think it's an interesting
angle to add there actually that
difficulty is one that faces a lot of
the casework that people working in
de-radicalization will speak about that
you can work with an individual but how
do you then give the person a future to
be able to make sure that there is no
other push the other thing you have to
represent you need in all of us are an
individual to get that kind of attention
and help they have to become already
someone who is identified as needing it
which usually is a perpetrator of some
sort someone who's been convicted or
caught or suspected of being in need of
that kind of help rather than perhaps
going out and seeking out
well it's of course easier to deal with
the consequences but you need to sort of
preempt that and what my colleagues are
really saying is you you have three
challenges firstly you have the
ideological challenge which indie
radicalization which they're far more
expert on mean doing in as a Western
liberal it's pointless secondly you need
this effective challenge which they've
sort of said that you need a different
reference point than the one he had
indeed in the piece we sort of saw that
in the unity group and the boxing where
he's got the sort of sense of belonging
and integration and the new reference
point and of course you need those
pragmatic challenges where you need
either education or housing and those
sorts of things now in the sense gives
you the spectrum of both your hard
counter extremism policies in terms of
he was locked up for being violent you
think could we imagine perhaps a world
where people like general chair listen
in on the community and then start
highlighting and drawing attention to
people like Russia rally we've got a few
guys here that you might be interested
in talking to they haven't done anything
wrong but from what we're listening in
on they could do with your kind of help
them it is that the kind of society
we're heading towards edge of tailing of
the to world trouble with this is that I
think that the first step that any
mentor and individual needs to go
through is having a mutual agreement and
this is something that's mutually
beneficial and actually a lot of the
people that get referred to a mentoring
scheme or adiabatic lows Asian process
I've actually been compelled at the
beginning to do that because it's part
of their sentencing term and that's not
easy then to engage with a person that
hasn't decided to come forward and
engage with a mentor one of the other
problems when you go into the
reintegration phase which is normally
towards the end of atomization process
is that that's a bit where the mental
loses control because they're not in
control of how this wider society is
going to welcome that person that
they've worked with over a long period
of time and the trouble with that is
that it's such a risk because if the
reintegration efforts don't work or fail
for whatever reason that then puts that
individual back thousand steps and even
could you could lose that individual so
much more than you did at the very
beginning and it can start to build him
to an individual's victim narrative in a
way that they think well I embraced
society but society didn't embrace me
back
and that's where it becomes really
tricky so that's why I would say that
the reintegration is the riskiest part
do you recognise Asian process this
historical story about the cultural
integrating of the European continent
with population moves and and the
general changes from the beginning of
the 20th century to say now a lot of
these issues were going to come along
anyway what parts of the kind of
push-pull factors of a group like is
play in making it harder or disturbing
it or would it have happened anyway
well I think there's there's there's two
very different things there the first is
I think we have actually had for
centuries Muslim populous Muslim
interaction within Europe and even
within Britain and I think that history
is often lost both in terms of people's
within the UK we know going back to the
famous to the oldest mosque you know
after Luke William or with you know the
Yemeni community in Wales etc that
you've actually had generations from the
turn of the last century and even before
that of those would be almost indigenous
to British society and having an
appreciation of broad British values the
rule of law the notion of separating
powers the notion of democratic
engagements so on and also the other
side that actually we have if you look
at and there's a great great work by em
I think is William Dalrymple one of his
travel writings on the white mogul in
his series looking at actually the other
way around the integration of British
Colonials within Indian society so we've
had that type of interaction both ways I
think that needs to be separated from
and the broader integration issues from
the discussion of de-radicalization and
radicalization in the sense that
actually they would always have issues
as a social phenomena the very specific
ideological radicalization is very very
particular okay so to look at the
alienation issues or lack of integration
issues in themselves they're not hooks
for extremist ideology they may be means
by which extremist ideology because more
attractive but actually it's the
ideology itself which then moves people
on towards considering violence and
terrorism that's where Isis actually is
a very very specific for
we've had thousands from Europe leave
Europe to form all of us what could be a
brigade of Fighters of Europeans that's
a final thought that we are out of time
but generally I just ask you about that
I can't you see a time as we move on say
five more years ten more years where
organisations like the military and GCHQ
and the police and special branch will
be cooperating more and more closely
with other other approaches from within
the community to try and do a sort of
umbrella approach can you see that
happening absolutely because partnership
is one of the things which was mentioned
in the counter extremist strategy of the
government and we must do that I can
also see a time when we defeat ia is and
that part of theology will go okay Major
General chip Chapman Emma Albert are we
and Russia rally thank you all for
coming and talking to us you see me here
on Sky News